can I ask you and if I'm is this too
personal you can say back off but how's
your romantic life going oh back off
Conan
[Laughter]
yeah uh you know Uncle Wayne huh yeah
Uncle Conan all right so grab your tea
how much is going on the best things
that goes on you know when you're 27th
yeah no I don't I don't know yeah yeah
nothing happened when I was 27 yeah no
it was a quiet quiet time in my life of
course it was the late 1950s we were all
worried about Sputnik but that's not the
point yeah we've got girly now uh no you
do don't stop keep going yeah
let's do more of that so uh what's the
dating scene uh like in Singapore
there's not much of AC you know it's say
well there is but not one that I don't
know goes well with me so I don't know
it's like I this this thing's happening
here and there I just you know I don't
really like to like put my finger on it
and be like oh that's the one for me or
it this thing's happening Conan things
are looking good though oh good positive
yeah oh so you got something brilliant
what's happening oh there's something is
there's a potential uh person out there
possibly yeah you can't jeopardize it
I'm not gonna jeopardize anything I just
want to know who this person is but you
can't she can't talk about it because
then he's gonna hear it and he's gonna
be like wait a minute this is moving too
fast for me because I've been there yes
I know unless he really really is into
her and is like like is bolstered by
this and then suddenly decides to make
more reciprocation because he feels
confidence that's what ladies like is
more reciprocation
nothing
so uh I would like to reciprocate with
you so you don't want to talk
specifically about this person just yet
yeah you don't want to look like
sabotage it you know
anyway when are you seeing him again
maybe maybe comment I don't know
get involved just tell us his name yeah
no guys I'm I'm with you D I'm gonna try
to comment down I need to get involved I
need to meet this guy yeah because D we
care about you we have a bond with you
and I don't want just some anybody
coming along right you know some uh you
know Johnny Singapore well that's his
name
I hate that guy I know this is why she
didn't want to say anything he didn't
quit it and reciprocate yeah
his name's Johnny Singapore call it off
now do you understand
hahaha
your parents get involved in this stuff
oh no not at all and no not at all I'm
very private I like to say except I just
sit this on the podcast yeah yeah but
you didn't I mean first of all
um yeah like No One's Gonna See this
anyway so it's fine okay
you just crossed a line dude
into telling the truth obviously hey if
no one said I'm gonna see it listen and
like with three other people
you would work you would you would fit
right into my organization yes yeah we
would be best friends you're like
Singapore Sona
you have my favorite cocktails you are
the Singapore soda we can just keep you
away from Singapore Johnny we're okay
yeah
um what's Singapore Conan do you think
yeah is there a is there a Singapore
version are there guys
I wish Conan I wish I've always thought
that like that was a Conan out there for
me
I'll be done I'll be settled oh wow
that's very flattering well I want to
tell all the ladies out there no matter
where you live in the world there's a
Conan out there for you what a person
for your door
stay off the streets until they catch
him tell your children about the dangers
of a Conan in your neighborhood is there
a Conan in your neighborhood stay low
um
yeah the whole campaign if you see
something say something started with uh
if there's a Conan in your on your
Subway teach your children how to spot a
Kona
is he 6'4 red beady eyes
like the Communists
his hair look like
a torque that would be served at a
French reception
tree blowing in the wind or Conan
be sure you know the difference
wow you're uh man you're a lot of fun D
I hope this guy listen here's my advice
to you you have to make sure that you
have high standards because you're a
special person you have to have high
standards and be honest Sona I do tell
this to the women that work for me yeah
yeah and I've always have that you
cannot settle you can't say okay good
enough you have to hold out well then
why are they working for you
[Laughter]
uh but if you get a chance to work for
sort of a shitty podcast operation grab
it